bienvenue au confins de l'Anjou du
Poitou et de la Touraine à l'abbaye
royale de Fontevraud c'est tout
simplement le plus vastant semble
monastique d'Europe depuis près d'un
millénaire
[Musique]
fondé en 1101 l'abbaye accueilli durant
cette siècle de nombreuses religieuses
de sang royal c'était une plateforme et
incontournable du royaume on est dans
l'église de Fontevraud avec de ce
côté-ci luisant d'aller Nord d'Aquitaine
qui a été reine de France puis
d'Angleterre de ce côté-ci vous avez son
deuxième époux qui est Henri deux
plantes je n'ai également à d'Angleterre
sans oublier le gisant de leur illustre
descendant Richard cœur de lion
Fontevraud demeure aujourd'hui encore
une nécropole royale de premier plan
la révolution sonne le glas de l'abbaye
Napoléon la transforme alors en 1804 en
l'un des centres carcéral les plus
impitoyables de France
les prisonniers ont investi tous les
bâtiments même dans l'église il y avait
trois niveaux d'ateliers et deux niveaux
de dortoir mais on a aussi créé des
bâtiments un petit peu partout la prison
a fermé ses portes en 1963 pour la
centrale et les derniers prisonniers ont
quitté l'abbaye en 1985
[Musique]
l'histoire de la vie continue à s'écrire
au quotidien depuis mai 2021 elle abrite
même un musée d'art moderne qui présente
près de 900 œufs
trek de gars buffet la collection
présentée provient d'une donation celle
du couple Cligman éclectique varier et
riche elle témoigne de l'évolution du
site
aujourd'hui c'est un centre culturel de
rencontre dans cet abbaye à ce titre on
accueille évidemment les visiteurs
extrêmement nombreux mais aussi les
artistes qui ont droit de citer ils
vivent ici ils travaillent ici il
produisent ici leurs œuvres qu'elles
soient des plastiques qu'elles soient
musicales et aujourd'hui le geste des
artistes et bien c'est la création
demain ce sera notre patrimoine
tout au long de l'année des rencontres
entre artistes en résidence des congrès
multidisciplinaires des expositions la
dernière en date au fil du sacré une
surprenante présentation de vêtements
liturgiques
l'originalité de cette exposition c'est
de présenter les vêtements des prêtres
essentiellement des chasuses sur le
thème de la création et quel que soit
l'époque c'est-à-dire depuis le 16e
siècle jusqu'au début du 21e siècle et
avec la participation des grandes
abbayes de savanderie de Solesmes où il
y avait des créateurs absolument hors
pair un étonnant patrimoine
particulièrement méconnu et une
diversité inattendue
[Musique]
ici on a des décors découpés dans le
costume d'un officier de la guerre de
1870 donc bleu horizon et rouge et là
nous arrivons devant la production de
l'abbaye de saint-andrille en Normandie
et les deux moines de saint-vendrillon
ont été inspirés par la mode féminine
des années 1930 des créations sous
influence principalement issues de
France mais aussi originaire d'Asie ou
d'Afrique toutes ces chasubles sont
magnifiques et c'est vrai qu'on est plus
dans la création que dans le côté
religieux je suis surprise de la qualité
de ce que l'on voit du côté étrange
c'est une merveille vraiment
[Musique]
une exposition à découvrir jusqu'au 30
janvier prochain en même temps que ce
site patrimonial exceptionnel
[Musique]